merci la parole est à Madame Catherine
procacia pour le groupe Union pour un
mouvement populaire merci monsieur le
Président ma question s'adresse donc à
Madame Touren après avoir tant critiqué
la réforme des retraite engagée par
François Fillon la qualifition d'injuste
de non financé je me réjouis que le
président François Hollande annonce que
le gouvernement est enfin prêt à faire
des choix courageux pour assurer
l'avenir de de retraite mais que
seront-ils le rapport du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites dit
clairement qu'il nous faut trouver 20
milliards d'ici 2020 pour éviter la
faillite du système 20 milliards et non
pas 47 qui aurait été nécessaire si nous
n'avions pas engager la réforme en 2010
je vous demande donc d'abandonner vos
attaques vous reconnaissez enfin que
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie doit
être pris en considération ce n'est
pourtant pas un fait qui date d'hier ni
de mai 2012 Madame la Ministre dimanche
vous avez déclaré que des efforts
seraient demandés à tous les français
puisque toucher l'âge de départ semble
complètement tabou à quels efforts
pensez-vous le gouvernement doit être
clair et honnête envers les Français
oserez-vous leur annoncer qu'ils devront
cotiser plus de 41 ans et demi ils ne
sont pas idiots ils vont faire le calcul
et ils verront que les 62 ans ne sont
qu'un leur mais même cela ne suffira pas
vous le savez en faisant sauter le
verrou des 62 ans cet été vous avez
donné un signal contradictoire aux
Français et dépenser 3 milliards mais
vous aveit aussi contraint les régimes
complémentaires à décider de désindexer
les pensions après avoir instauré à
l'automne une nouvelle contribution à la
charge et retraité allez-vous continuer
à les paupériser ils sont moins des
nantis que vous aimez le faire croire je
voudrais donc vous poser trois questions
précises madame la ministre que
comptez-vous faire avec les salariés des
régimes spéciaux vont-ils continuer à
être exemptés des futurs efforts à
pouvoir partir en retraite à 52 ans
comme les cheminau ou à 57 ans comme les
autres agents de la SNCF et de la RATP
2ème question prenez-vous aujourd'hui
madame la ministre l'engagement de
présenter votre réforme devant le
Parlement et non de légiférer par
ordonnance
enééar finanement jusqu'à 2030 celle que
vous allez nous proposer aura-elle les
ambitions de Cell que vous nous
réclamiez merci Madame marieouren
ministre des Affaires sociales et de la
santé merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la
sénatriceine effectivement nous avons
indiqué que la réforme du précédent
gouvernement n'était ni juste ni financé
et si d'ailleurs votre réforme avait été
juste et financé nous n'aurions pas
besoin aujourd'hui de remettre l'ouvrage
sur le métier et c'est parce que votre
réforme était injuste que nous avions
pris l'engagement et que nous avons tenu
l'engagement dès notre arrivée aux
responsabilités de permettre à celles et
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler
jeunes qui ont la totalité de leurs
années cotisées de pouvoir partir en
retraite des 60 ans et c'est parce que
votre réforme n'était pas financée que
nous avons dû engager des travaux nous
permettant d'amorcer une nouvelle
réforme vous me permettrez madame la
sénatrice de saisir l'occasion que vous
me donnez pour saluer l'engagement des
partenaires sociaux et leur sens des
responsabilités qui leur a permis
d'aboutir à un compromis cette nuit leur
engagement pour que les régimes
complémentaires de retraite qui
contribuent pour une part significative
à la retraite des salariés ayant
travaillé dans le privé soit assuré dans
la durée parce que voyez-vous madame la
sénatrice c'est cela l'exigence du
gouvernement c'est de faire en sorte que
dans la durée nos régimes de retraite
par répartition soit
c'est de faire en sorte que dans la
durée les Français puissent compter sur
une retraite versée grâce à la
solidarité nationale or aujourd'hui les
jeunes générations sont inquiètes nous
avons donc commandé un rapport au
Conseil d'orientation des retraites qui
a été rendu mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs qui a été rendu et qui fait
état d'un déficit de l'ordre de 20
milliards d'euros d'ici 2020 une
commission s'est installée qui audition
a notamment les partenaires sociaux
aboutira à des pistes de propositions
qui devront nous permettre d'agir dans
trois direction la première c'est celle
du financement à court terme de nos
régimes de retraite pour que les
Français soient assurés de la pérénité
de nos régimes la deuxième orientation
qui a été prise par le gouvernement
c'est celle de consolider dans la durée
les régime de retraite par répartition
et enfin nous nous sommes engagés à
introduire des mesures d'équité c'estes
mesures nous allons y travailler je ne
doute pas madame la sénatrice que vous y
apporterez une contribution utile pour
l'ensemble des Français